hợp của lúc gặp ở Oskrilia, Mát Tinh, dừng vệnh hoặc sinh ở Bianh, Thà Tinh.
Hà Tinh, hai người qua, mặt xa hội lãnh truyền Tinh đã học của lúc gong thông bá cho các đại dí từ sĩnh ở Việt Nam,
là không nhận hối sơ của hợp sinh ở Năm Tính thành, bao gồm hay phòng, nghe ăn, Thà Tinh,
gọi bình và hay dương từ ngày người lạm thả tả tảnh.
Vua ra, chung công công các khoa học tinh anh kết thợp.
yêu cầu bộ xung hồ sơ tại chính với học sinh cả nước, chưa bao tình vụ lớn là thành phố Holt Chiming,
hà Nội và Đà Nắng, tên này được chơi sẻ trên nhiều dễ đàn,
kể sẽ tất lần đoàn phy lý rau học sinh năm để phương lời trên bị tì choi.
Chá lời vì an expect tối nể hả bị bốt thả mười, lại dễn của lúc gong cho biết,
nhận đoàn đăng ký tự tất cả các phùm về của Việt Nam,
và đã thông bá việc lại với các đại lý tựa sĩnh từ thả chính,
của lúc gong không ốc sự dưới hạn, lời với hồ sơ đăng ký tự Việt Nam,
hợp bất ký cức xa nào khác, người lại nói tất cả đơn đăng ký được lạnh sát theo tâm sự hợp của thế,
theo chương lợp bộ bộ bộ ốc sfeil lìa dưới trí các quy định,
giám đảm bảo sinh về chân chính đến học tập,
và vô lòng gong tôn thủ các thương sạch này để hỗ trợ sinh về chân quá trình sinh tị thương.
Chương cho biết, suho khách sinh về là một trong những uống sinh về của tế lần nhất tại của lòng gong.
Mà gồm, vô lòng gong kháu sơ, nếu cung cấp thách chương chính trình trình tiếp,
bảo tình anh học nè với hơn một kiên người.